من داخل احدى مدارس الاواء هنا في مدينه
رفح جنوبي قطاع غزه ثله من الاطباء الذين
نزحوا قصرا من مشافي قطاع غزه الى المنطقه
الجنوبيه اكملوا مهمتهم الانسانيه ولم
يتوقفوا في اسعاف ومتابعه الحاله الصحيه
للاجئين الفلسطينيين والنازحين في ظل
الظروف الصحيه الصعبه التي يواجهها هؤلاء
في هذا المركز انا الحكيم محمد يوسف ماضي
من سكان غزه كننت شغال في مستشفى الرنتيسي
رئيس قسم الجراحه بعد ما تم تحويل مستشفى
الرنتيسي لقسم جراحه تابع للشفا ول
الاندونيسي اي كنا نستقبل حالات من
المصابين مستشفى الرنتيسي وتعامل معهم
استمر الحال هذا لمده 30 يوم تقريبا في
الحرب من بدايه الحرب لعند 30 يوم بعد هيك
تم محاصره مستشفى الرنتيسي بحسب الخطه
الصهيونيه محاصره المستشفيات وتم اجبار
على الخروج ا من المستشفى بعد هيك
استكملنا دورنا ونزح على الجنوب
اي لمدينه رفح هنا انشانا هنا في المدرسه
بتاع
القدس نقطه طبيه لمعالجه النازحين
ومتابعتهم الاماكن المزدحمه زي ما انت
شايف هذه بتكون عرضه لانتشار الامراض خاصه
الامراض الجلديه الامراض التنفسيه وال
والامراض النزلات المعويه هذا دورنا
الانساني اللي احنا اصلا يعني بدينا فيه
وان شاء الله حنكمل للاسف انه ما فيش
ادويه احنا بنطلع على العيادات وعلى
المستشفيات الموجوده في رفح هنا ونحصل هيك
شويه حاجات بعض الادويه اللي مش موجوده
بنشوف حد من فاعلين الخير بقدر يعني
يوفرها لكن للاسف حتى الصيدليات بعض
الادويه مش موجوده يعني نزحنا من مستشفى
شفاء في اخر الفترات خلال الاخلاء
الاجباري من قبل الاحتلال وتوجهنا من
مستشفى دار الشفاء اجمع
الطواقم الطبيه والمصابين والنازحين من
مستشفى دار الشفاء الى الممر الامن ثم
نزحنا بالحالات المصابه الى مستشفى دار
السلام ومستشفى ناصر تمت المتابعه للحالات
الطارئه ومن ثم نزحنا الى مدرسه القدس في
رفح قمنا بعمليات انزاله ومشن على الاقدام
حملهم او سندهم من خلال السند الايد الكتف
تحمل الحاله كانت صعبه الامور كان هناك
اطلاق نار متعمد من قبل الاحتلال عل برص
في الم على الممر الامن خاص بالذات لم يصب
احد ولكن كان هناك قصف
طائرات حربيه ومدافع وكان هناك تعطيل
للمرور من صباح يوم الاخلاء الى ليله كنا
نتواصل من خلال الرسائل كل بعض عده ايام
وليس كل
يوم كنت من ثاني يوم الحرب وانا في قسب
العمليات اتواصل معهم من خلال الرسائل فقط
نزحنا من خلال الاخلاء الاجبا يعني
الاخلاء الاجباري بعد شهر ونصف تقريبا
ووصلت الى مدينه رفح وانا بعيدا عن اهلي
وزوجتي وابنائي لمده لا تقل عن الشهر
ونصف كانت الطريق صعبه وطريقه التواصل
صعبه جدا كنا من
بعض الجوالات نتواصل معهم عن طريق الرسائل
اتفقنا على ان نواصل
طريق النضال وخدمه الحالات الانسانيه من
واجبنا الاخلاقي
والمهني واحنا طبعا في ظروف صعبه جدا
الناس مش حتقدر تعمل اي شيء احنا في حتى
مرحله النزوح كملنا طريقنا ولازم نواصله
ونخدم الناس هذا واجبنا الوطني والاخلاقي
نزحوا قصرا وغادروا مواقع العمل عنوه
لكنهم لم يتركوا العمل الانساني ال واصل
بكل جد واجتهاد ودون مقابل هان الشاعر
لقناه الجزيره مدينه
رفح